[Musique]
voilà ce qui attend tous les mosellans
sans exception dès lundi minuit ils
devront présenter un test négatif de -2
48 heures pour aller en allemagne
l'allemagne a en effet classé le
département français en zone à forte
circulation est des variantes éléments
qui m'inquiète dans la décision
allemande c'est qu'en fait elle est
probablement à l'image de ce que de ce
qui peut nous arriver si nous continuons
à décrocher par rapport à ce que font
nos voisins
la commission européenne a lancé l'idée
la semaine dernière et c'est très
inquiétant d'un corridor sanitaire
touristique 191 kilomètres heure et oui
c'est la vitesse à laquelle roulait and
automobilistes bon déjà c'est très au
dessus de la vitesse autorisée
autre spécificité de cette information
c'est que l'automobiliste avait 88 ans
la france risque de n'être pas classé
dans une zone sanitaire safa sécurisé et
donc toute cette industrie du tourisme
s'écroulait il s'est justifié en
expliquant qu'il était en retard à son
rendez-vous de pour se faire vacciner
contre le vide 19h confinement il est
inévitable pour vous alors qu'ils
réclament c'est de la place de soignants
oui je pense qu'il est inévitable et je
me lévy table parce que
on ne peut pas vivre avec ce niveau de
pression sur l'hôpital
confiné paris et la petite couronne le
week-end j'ai dit mon désaccord avec
cette proposition
une proposition que je trouve difficile
dure voire même inhumaine
ce matin emmanuel macron lors d'un
échange informel avec des jeunes a
semblé esquisser un horizon il faut
tenir encore quelques semaines quatre à
six semaines
en clair le temps que les vaccins se
déploie hélas sur les quatre à six
prochaines semaines
il faut pas compter qu'on réduisent la
voilure des mesures il faudra le
confinement le couvre-feu pardon et les
mesures actuelles seront un minimum sur
les quatre à six prochaines semaines et
nous espérons évidemment ne pas aller au
delà il sort sans un mot nicolas sarkozy
vient d'apprendre qu'il est condamné à
trois ans de prison dont un ferme
dur aussi pour l'avocat de nicolas
sarkozy qui ne peut plus exercer pendant
cinq ans et tous les ténors de la droite
en défilé par téléphone ou à coup de
tweets pour soutenir l'ex président il y
a manifestement eu effectivement un
acharnement judiciaire contre nicolas
sarkozy qui n'a pas été traité comme un
justiciable comme les autres
il y à des juges qui ont décidé et là il
y aurait aujourd'hui d'avoir la portée
politique de nicolas fait reconnaît
aujourd'hui d'autres demain attention à
cela n'entre démocrates ont besoin
on a le sentiment qu'on est rentré dans
une république des juges que les juges
veulent se faire nicolas sarkozy qu'ils
veulent se faire un certain nombre de
politiques avec lesquels ils ont des
désaccords au delà même d'un regard sur
le d'un regard sur le droit femmes en
cette décision est assez hallucinante et
on a voulu porter l'infamie sur nicolas
sarkozy
je crois que chaque homme politique en
responsabilité va avoir ce jugement
comme celui de françois fillon aussi
dans un autre domaine et
ce sera le principe de précaution absolu
pour tous nous allons former un appel
contre cette décision que le président
évidemment conteste cette profanation
que cette condamnation suscite à la fois
notre incompréhension mais aussi je dois
dire notre indignation au delà de la
sanction qui qui encore une fois
totalement disproportionnée ça pose le
sujet de l'existence même du parc
national financier de ces méthodes
et puis de son indépendance que je vous
ai manqué
beaucoup de choses se sont passées mais
chacun sait l'affection le respect que
j'ai pour nicolas sarkozy qui a été un
grand président de la république et qui
en ces moments difficiles
évidemment mon soutien et mon soutien
amical qui sait peut-être vais-je décidé
de les battre une troisième fois